today we're going to present you for the
first time in public our new product so
JavaScript debugging robots we're young
startup we're based out of Switzerland
and we came all the way to here to
present this you know just before I
start a bit of background this is
Switzerland right its last in the middle
of Europe it's about as big as sorry
that maybe even smaller I don't I don't
know and there's usually you know this
confusion between Sweden and Switzerland
so we're from Switzerland Sweden this is
that is ikea switzerland it's Swiss
cheese right so I'm outback buster so
we'll have robots and I I get you know
everybody loves robot because you know
they do lots of useful things for you
for instance you can buy a robot to you
no mo your loan if you have a garden you
can buy robots to clean your floor or
scare your pets depending on you know
what you want to do or you can even you
know have this really cool flying
quadcopters through it so you know all
these you know robots they're really
nice because they're going to do all the
things that you don't really want to do
yourself but if there is one thing that
you that we want to do is you know
programming right if we all love
programming especially in JavaScript
otherwise you would you know be on the
beach or somewhere else you know I don't
have to teach you you know how great
jazz give is you know you can do a great
server-side application with nodejs or
program robots now you know they're
these cool operating system for mobile
you know Firefox OS or Chrome OS for you
know with your nice Chromebook so really
a lot of things that you can do with
with JavaScript what we really don't
like is that you know bugs on you know
it's a fact of life if you write code
you can have you know some of these at
some point you know that's not good but
this cannot be helped right you know you
just you know you're just gonna have to
handle them but let me just give you a
very simple example this is taken from a
website it's a it's a simple form to you
know sign up to the mailing list and
this is the code that is behind it so
it's a you know JavaScript using jquery
and the only thing that it does it
handles the submit events and then it
uses a regular expression to parse the
email
to make sure it is syntactically valid
and if it is then it submits the form so
how can you know what can possibly go
wrong here right it's only you know less
than 20 lines of code right well first
you cool you know make a mistake with
you know the CSS selector and not get
the right value or not get any value at
all for doing others then you could make
a mistake you know in the regular
expression no that never happens but and
then if it does happen well that you
know this if statement over here is not
going to you know do the right thing so
you might actually submit something in
value to the server or you know prevent
somebody from submitting something valid
so that's not good and then even if all
this code is correct you're going to
post a request to a server and then the
server is going to do God knows what you
know work with the database with some
other services and might you know blow
up so you might have a pound or two and
then of course they're a bunch of you
know function calls you know other
pieces of code that may also have
problems so it's a very simple example
there are about 13 lines of useful code
in there you know there are about six
lines where you could possibly have a
problem someday and that's not even
counting problems with libraries so that
example was using jQuery well I guess
jQuery is pretty stable but you know you
called upgrade to a newer version of
jQuery and all of seven hats you know
some unexpected behavior so something
will break sooner or later so what can
you do to you know make things better
well it could use a strongly typed
language maybe but you know this example
was syntactically valid you know there
is no type problems and still you know
there are lots of you know places where
you could have issues you could use
better compilers or you know compilers
to begin with but again that example
there I mean it wouldn't help right
because you know the problem you know
with CSS selectors that kind of stuff
there is nothing a compiler can do now
you can try to implement some very fancy
static analysis tool that was suddenly
be useful but you know the problem with
static analysis is it has to speculate
about what your input is going to look
like so you know in general it's going
to be difficult to prove or disprove
that you know something's going to work
or not so in the end of your left with
testing
the only solution you know if you really
want to make sure that you know your
thing is going to work or time and not
break so speaking a little bit about you
know testing techniques right so what
are the you know techniques out there
well obviously you can test your code
manually when it's just you know mailing
list signup well that's not too much
work you can you can do it yourself but
you know in general you have better
things to do than keep you know on
clicking and typing stuff to see if it
works then you can write unit tests
which is very useful and you should
definitely do that but if not as easy
for instance if you have a server or if
you have some you know fancy libraries
you can have to mark stuff on you know
it's not necessarily easy to test that
the entire stack and then finally you
can write integration tests using
selenium or phantom jet and that's
basically the only solution if you want
to test the entire stack and so you
would write something like that just you
know just wrote the flu a few lines it's
relatively easy but the problem is
basically forces you to write more codes
right so you're testing code and you
have to write more code that's basically
the testing products that we have
nowadays right so the additional code
that you would not you write in order to
test your you know your feature has to
be debugged as well and has to be
maintained over time as well and so at
bug buster our vision is to try to solve
this problem using a robot so sorry to
disappoint you it's not a physical robot
it's a software robot it's just you know
piece of software but basically does the
same thing as your vacuum cleaner right
it goes around your code and tries to
find you know the dirty places that's
basically so what it does is it explores
your HTML and javascript by itself so it
basically uses the application and while
it does that it detects bugs on top of
it we have a very expressive timing
insensitive API that enables you to
control the robot a little bit a little
bit better and the goal with this is to
be is to test a lot more with less code
so speaking about automatic exploration
of code how does it work so it's fairly
simple to understand first you know back
with you is going to load your
application then it's going to supply
input first
trigger an event somewhere by typing a
value or clicking on a button then it's
going to analyze the even handler code
basically as it is executing and it's
going to you know unfold the control
flow graph so basically if you have if
statements and stuff like that in an
event handler it's going to enfold that
and it's going to figure out that there
are various sides you know of these if
statements and then it's going to try to
generate new input in order to cover the
different sides of these if statements
and if you can do that then it will go
back to step 2 step 2 in order to supply
additional input trigger again the same
even handler and uncover the other parts
of the code so if I continue with my
signup example the first thing is going
to do is well it will figure out that
there is one input field so it's going
to type a value in there and a that will
not trigger any events so it will just
carry on and do something else so what
it will do is it will click on the sign
up button that will trigger the event
handler uncover the first if the first
part of this if statement over here what
this if statement does is you know it
runs this regular expression to test to
test the validity of the of the input
the input here is a it's not a valid
email address it doesn't match the
regular expression so it stops there so
what it will do it will actually resolve
this regular expression to figure out
another piece of input that could be
typed into this text field instead and
so it if it successfully does that then
it can type something else in the typing
in the text field so in this example it
will you know type something that looks
random but it's actually not random at
all it really matches the regular
expression and so it types it again and
clicks again on the sign up button and
now it has covered the entire code for
this even handler so that enables you to
get great code coverage and to find you
know if there is an exception or if
there is you know an assertion or
something like that that fires in this
piece of code then it will catch it and
report it what is this good for several
things first you can use that for
exploratory testing so this is for
instance you know
have an application it may be new or
maybe you don't know it very well you
can you know launch your robot and it
let it do you know different things see
see what happens and get an assessment
of the code quality you can also do use
these to do more systematic testing so
one problem when people are writing test
cases is that you know they have sort of
a conception of how the code works so
they're going to write the test cases
you know by following this sort of
mental model that I have on so they may
miss you know corner cases by analyzing
the source code we're actually able to
try and cover as much of the code as
possible including the corner cases so
you can you can use that to to
systematically test you could so it's a
very useful for testing large code base
you know very often people don't have
the time to you know write all the test
cases that they will want to write for
the code base or maybe the code base
moves too quickly so maintaining the
test case is difficult so you can use
these robots to to tell help you do that
finally it's it's a cool tool for
continuous testing you can you know put
that into your Jenkins or whatever
Travis and run the rapid as frequently
as you want so I was saying before that
we also have an API well just because
you know when you run the robot in a
optimally exploration mode well it might
start doing things that you're not
interested about right that doesn't mean
it's not interesting but you know my
delay you know you for little why
because you will have to wait until it
gets to the place where you want to test
your application so we have an API that
we call the connector API that is there
to control the robot to direct it and
also to leverage automatic exploration
and that enables to test functional
properties here's an example of how this
API look looks like it's it's also a
JavaScript API so the first few lines
just to you know started the test
session so you can load the URL and you
say you know I want to do the automatic
exploration but then it's not because
it's not in automat it's an automatic
exploration that you cannot direct it so
you can actually write a few lines to
tell it exactly what to do so allein 8
to 11 you can you know click type
and click again so this is an example
where you do a sign in so if you know to
provide a username and a password you
can do that very easily you can see here
the you know timing insensitive property
of this API so if you actually need to
click on a menu before you know doing
the next the next operation on your
application by Buster actually since its
you know embedded deep into the into the
browser it actually figures out if you
know there are Ajax requests or if they
have if there are timers and that kind
of things and it will wait in between
two actions that you're queuing before
it executes them so you don't have to
explicitly write code between your click
and another click to prevent the robot
from you know being too fast now that's
for the sign in and then you know if you
want to verify that you're actually you
know logged in properly in your
application you can use a watcher a
watcher is basically an event emitters
it that spies on the state of your
application and that triggers and even
when something specific happens so in
this example is when some 11 shows up in
the application so that enables you to
spy on your application and then you
want to encode the fact that you know
this test session is going to be
successful if you properly logged in on
unsuccessful otherwise so for that you
can use a goal so a goal is a promise
that basically says in this test in this
test session the sign-in should work if
it's not explicitly fulfilled before the
end of the test session then you can
have a bug reported but if it is like in
this example you know in this watcher if
we see the element sign then then we
know that we're logged in properly so we
can fulfill the goal and you know
everybody's happy that's an example of
our I of our API in terms of technology
we're building all of that inside web
kits or we have a heavily customized
version of JavaScript code to do an
instrumentation of the JavaScript and to
figure out all these input values we now
have beta version that is online so i
encourage you to
it's completely free and we'd like to
get as much feedback from you guys as
possible that's why we're here today and
we're also considering porting our
technology to v8 in order to provide the
same technology for four no Jess so if
you think that's interesting let us know
that will definitely motivate us so I'm
getting near the end of my talk and
before I'm before I stop just you know
wanted to cry 5 one thing if you're
doing test-driven development of
behavior driven development if you're
writing unit tests or selenium test
cases by you know by all means keep
doing it and by we're not saying that
you should you should stop doing this
what we try to achieve here is to
provide a way to test more not less so
you can use these robots to basically
try to cover as much of your code as
possible and to complement whatever test
cases you already have but if you're
reading you know if you're using and
development mythology that you know
where you write your test cases keep
doing this that's the best that's the
best thing that you can do all right
that completes my talk there are three
of us here danielle and avenue and of
course myself so if you think this is
interesting if you like to see a demo or
just want to talk about technology just
you know come to us thanks a lot
you